et comme à saintes odin plusieurs
petites villes souffrent des départs à
répétition des entreprises alors les
gouvernements successifs ont ils failli
dans leur mission de maintenir l'emploi
en france comment attirer à nouveau les
industries l'état at il abandonné ses
territoires on attend vos réactions sur
le conte télégramme et place à notre
décryptage
[Musique]
avec mon pour en parler loïc prud'hommes
députés elle est fille de gironde en
soir loïc prénomme merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés jacques myard maire de
maisons laffitte bonsoir jacques myard
merci d'être là on entend ce cri
d'alarmé un poignant du maire de saint
claude 1 qui se bat comme un beau diable
obligé même de réduire son chauffage à
l'école pour faire des économies la fota
qui loïc prud'hommes à la
désindustrialisation
votre réaction après ce témoignage
écoutez je ne connais pas le maire de
saint claude mais je pense qu'ils posent
un diagnostic et une analyse qui sont
très justes il part notamment de ces
politiques libérales qui année après
année soit disant devait permettre plus
de prospérité mais de libéral et
libertés il n'y a rien en fait tout ça
et est aliéné aux règles du marché et
règles du marché on le voit c'est la
concurrence de tous contre tous une
compétitivité au niveau du continent
européen tout entier est juste faire le
constat que quoi que l'on fasse il y
aura toujours quelqu'un pour produire
moins cher au plus allemand qui si on
pourrait le faire et donc c'est un
combat sans fin et vous pourrez faire
des plans en france relance autant que
vous en voudrez vous n'arriverez pas à
relocaliser d'une manière pérenne et
durable une industrie dans le pays en
fait ces règles de compétition qui songe
à dire sans foi ni loi qui autorise
cette question cette façon de faire et
du coup aux coudres des emplois
autant qu'on en crée autant on en perd
jacques myard cette fonte de rien et bf2
de saint-claude c'était évidemment un
outil industriel indispensable dans un
dans un bassin d'emploi hyper sinistrés
cette entreprise il y en a plein
d'autres dans plein de village français
la faute à qui pour vous êtes d'accord
avec le diagnostic de loïc prud'hommes
la faute au libéralisme et vacanciers au
manque de volonté politique
il y à un double phénomène qui a été
celui le dogme dogma de ces dernières
années il ya d'abord eu la purge
bruxelloise en matière il faut les
respecter les 3% fallait couper dans le
fonctionnement et on a coupé dans les
investissements la france n'a pas
investi ces vingt dernières années à la
hauteur de ce qu'elle aurait dû faire
c'est une évidence ne sait pas les
marchés qui doivent gouverner c'est une
question de politique industrielle
d'investissement et la france n'a pas
investi peux vous dire qu'il ya deux ans
je regardais l'ensemble des dépenses
publiques sur 580 milliard c'est à dire
avec le budget la cité sociale il y
avait 2 %
d'investissement de l'état ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point c'est
l'aménagement du territoire parce que ce
mr vous l'a dit il tente de faire venir
des gens chez lui effectivement au lieu
de tout concentrer dans des régions
comme paris où on bétonne à longueur de
temps voir le rhône alpes il faut
retrouver l'aménagement du territoire et
faire venir des entreprises ce qui
signifie qui pourra avoir le courage de
dire à bruxelles arrêter cette politique
stupide de tout concurrence pour
retrouver de la politique industrielle
et retrouvés l'aménagement du territoire
il vaut mieux créer aider les
entreprises à s'installer dans des
villes comme saint claude au lieu de
faire venir
aujourd'hui
à vienne où ils auront beaucoup de
difficultés à se loger et ou en
concentrent toutes les difficultés donc
il faut changer radicalement de
politique et gestes hier que le débat
des présidentielles sort à cette
occasion en tout cas c'est un aveu assez
claire de votre part est assez honnête
une forme d'impuissance notamment face à
la politique de bruxelles votre réaction
logique prud'hommes parce que c'est vrai
que les gouvernements successifs de
droite de gauche comme de droite n'ont
pas fait mieux les uns des autres il
était alors j'ai pas mémoire qui eut un
gouvernement d'une gauche comme moi je
la représente récemment en français
par exemple
oui effectivement donc ce n'est pas un
gouvernement de gauche et des politiques
libérales et notamment la question de
l'absence de volonté politique notamment
quand on voit au niveau de l'union
européenne la façon dont on a libéralisé
par exemple le secteur des transports
qui permet à ce que les les industries
se délocaliser dans des pays voisins et
puis que les produits finalement de
consommation reviennent ici pour
quelques euros de plus et puis sur la
question des fonderies parce que saint
claude est vraiment un exemple
intéressant moi j'étais au printemps
dernier aux fonderies du poitou qui sont
en train de fermer puisque pour quelques
euros sur le carter d'un moteur d'une
voiture française un carter en alu pour
quelques euros sur des voitures à
plusieurs milliers d'euros les
fabricants vont délocaliser à l'autre
bout de l'europe pour pour gagner
quelques points de marge et pour servir
quoi finalement pas pour servir
l'industrie des soins du pays pas pour
être utile aux consommateurs mais pour
verser des dividendes mais pour assurer
une rentabilité encore plus importante
aux capitaux donc ça c'est un vrai souci
les puits sur la question de
l'aménagement territoire je ne peux pas
ne pas mentionner aussi les décisions
politiques de ces derniers mois quand
vous avez ce gouvernement qui fait des
ponts d'or des tapis rouge à des
plateformes comme amazon au détriment
des tissus de petites entreprises de
moyenne entreprise ou en même de
d'industrie françaises on peut faire
tous les plans coeur de ville que l'on
veut si on permet en même temps de
développer c'est hyper plateforme à nos
portes dans nos villages aux portes de
nos métropoles et ben tous âges à dire
c'est une politique des shadows quoi ça
n'aboutira à rien on va brasser du vent
varroase de l'air mais ça ne créera
aucun emploi et ça ne permettra pas de
réindustrialiser durablement notre pays
on va regarder ces sources de l'insee 1
qui nous donne un petit peu un état des
lieux en regarder les rockets
relocalisation sont désormais tout de
même
nombreuses que les fermetures du sinn je
vous laisse découvrir ce graphique un
nombre d usines fermées les années
c'est voilà 87 nom d'organisation en
2021 c'est beaucoup plus que les années
précédentes
le la crise sanitaire j'ai que mes
arrêts ce qu'elle a finalement suscité
une lueur d'espoir rien et surtout une
soif de changement on a réalisé beaucoup
de choses à cette occasion qu on était
peut-être un peu trop dépendant d'autres
contrées
coûter malheureusement la pandémie n'a
pas aidé beaucoup parce que il est
évident que pour
reconquérir des des terrains perdu pour
mettre en oeuvre un aménagement du
territoire la pandémie a freiné
justement ce moment mais je voudrais
insister vous quand on s'est mis à
fabriquer des masques
dans les
liquidations saint jacques mais alpha on
a fabriqué des masques et des jeans on a
quand même parce que moi compris qu'on
n'en avait pas et qu'il fallait les
fabriquer nous mêmes attendez attendez
attendez c'est pas avec la fabrication
des masques qui je souhaite pas se
terminer rapidement on va
réindustrialiser le pays pour être
sérieux ce qui se passe ce qui est
effectivement le tout concurrence de
bruxelles a permis de concurrencer des
entreprises au sein même de l'union
européenne dont certaines dans certains
pays ont des monnaies sous-évaluées est
par exemple si vous prenez le cas de
l'allemagne elle fait fabriquer tout un
tas d'éléments de son industrie en
tchéquie et ensuite les réintègre dans
ces machines qu'elle exporte donc elle
gagne sur tous les tableaux un lan
monnaie sous-évaluée par rapport à sa
puissance de l arrêt at elle des
éléments de son industrie fabriqués à
bas coûts par exemple en tchéquie ou en
pologne donc ça peut pas marcher et
c'est là où on est les cocus de
l'histoire parce que aujourd'hui il pour
pouvoir avoir une concurrence loyale et
non faussée il faut avoir je dirais une
monnaie beaucoup plus adapté à ce qu'est
notre puissance industrielle ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on ne peut pas investir dans
des créneaux dans des niches et fabriqué
effectivement demain une industrie qui
montera mais il faut les aider c'est à
l'industrie il faut mettre en place des
systèmes de financement pour
l'investissement en haut de bilan c'est
à dire prendre des participations pour
pouvoir aider le décollage de ces
entreprises donc c'est tout un ensemble
a changé parce que avant c'était le tout
marché c'était mâcon jupiter en disant
que les horloges le maître des horloges
ce sont les marchés non il faut
retrouver un ministre de l'industrie
avec de la prévision pour pouvoir
justement investi en grande concertation
dans les industries qui peuvent faire
décoller l'industrie française à nouveau
lui prudemment à la france a soumis ce
vous avez ce type de projet qu'elle
saurait vous les mesures en faveur de la
vallée contre la décentralisation de la
france mais écoutez moi je bois du petit
lait puisque j'ai l'impression que
monsieur meyer finalement est devenu
insoumis parce que il s'aperçoit
effectivement que les politiques
libérales sont un échec mais oui non
mais
il a plutôt à une otarie stadification
très bien très bien donc oui la
planification il faut bien sûr le faire
mais je voudrais rajouter quand même une
de nos propositions et je pense que du
coup monsieur meyer va s'y rallier c'est
la question du protectionnisme que nous
proposons parce que il faut
effectivement un protectionnisme social
pour éviter qu'ils aient du dumping ou à
nos portes sur ce que nous pouvons
produire ici vous vous parliez de
souveraineté ça ne pourra se faire qu'à
ce prix là et puis également la question
du dumping environnemental ou aussi on
voit produire notamment je pense aux
produits alimentaires parce que la
réindustrialisation s'est aussi retrouvé
des tissus de production et
l'agriculture
participent à recréer des emplois c'est
le protectionnisme environnemental pour
que des choses qui ce que je disais tout
à l'heure produite plus salement que
chez nous à côté d'eux puisse pas
rentrer librement ici donc un
protectionnisme pour arrêter ce camping
et la question de la fin des droits de
douane a provoqué cette cet effondrement
majeur de notre industrie en france
c'est évident tva sociale il faut une
tva sociale à l'entrée des produits sur
le territoire en libre pratique de
l'union européenne c'est comme cela que
l'on pourra effectivement je dirais
prélevés sur des importations à bas
coûts fabriqués dans des pays où on
traite mal les ouvriers mal les cadres
que l'on pourra effectivement financer
notre projet social ce qui fonctionne
sur une section détachée davantage de
souverainisme
c'est davantage d'intelligence le
souverain se sépare un repli sur soi
c'est de regarder comment ça fonctionne
et de mettre des écluses là où c'est
nécessaire mais d'abord un travail était
taché alors je voudrais vous faire
tamponner par exemple aussi c'est une
escroquerie le travail détaché à oui
mais ça la faute à l'europe jacques
myard vous faisiez partie des longtemps
je vous dis il ya longtemps vous
indigner effectivement non non non non
mais le problème moi vous savez je suis
pas un clown et je pense pas moi même je
ne vais pas chercher dans des slogans je
dirais deux parties et des appareils la
solution à nos problèmes ça fait 15 ans
20 ans que je dis que l'union européenne
va dans le mur eh bien on y est vous
n'aviez donc pas d'agir signé le traité
européen de 2005
certainement pas j'ai voté contre j'ai
voté contre maastricht contre le traité
constitutionnel et contre une bonne
parce que ça ça a été une étude est une
escroquerie intellectuelle
alors on va découvrir une première
réaction tout de suite à la question de
savoir si l'état abandonné ses
territoires marie on le dit de toute
façon les politiques viennent
n que pendant les campagnes
présidentielles dans les campagnes le
reste du temps ils nous ignorent loïc
prud'hommes c'est vrai qu'on les voit
sont dans des filets on se souvient de
marine le pen
emmanuel macron notamment lors d'un face
à face assez médiatisé chez les cons qui
depuis beaucoup des usines ont fermé
cette fois ci est ce qu'on en a tiré les
leçons pour cette nouvelle campagne est
ce que les promesses seront tenues selon
vous ben nous en tout cas on veut se
prémunir des promesses non tenues parce
que notamment ont dit que les élus de la
france info visé dans notre sixième
république seront révocables s'ils ne
tiennent pas leurs promesses mais c'est
ce que je vous disais au début c'est que
finalement ça fait 30 ans 40 ans qu'on a
des gouvernements libéraux alors
certains les ont appelées de gauche mais
moi je je récuse ce terme là on n'a
jamais essayé des gens un peu sérieux un
peu conséquents comme comme jean luc
mélenchon à la france insoumis sur les
questions de planification de
protectionnisme social environnemental
et donc le voyez je pense que là dessus
en a raison et monsieur myard le disais
je le salue que quand on raisonne un
petit peu et que l'on se range pas
derrière des dogmes du libéralisme
on comprend que cette organisation
aujourd'hui des marchés est une faillite
absolue à tous les points et donc c'est
ça qu'il faut maintenant remettre à
l'endroit et oui à un candidat sérieux
qui peut permettre de faire ce cette
bifurcation rapidement
5 milliard émaner de ma croix a tout de
même fait de la reine décès isation de
la france l'une de ses priorités même si
pour l'instant le milan n'est guère
satisfaisant à vous entendre je me
propose de regarder à son plan vous
parliez de plans un investissement
france 2030 avec ces différentes
propositions pour relancer l'économie
française crée de l'emploi c'est un plan
qui qui peut sauver notre industrie
selon vous écoutez ça vient bien tard
pourquoi voulez vous faire confiance à
quelqu'un qui a mené qui vient de faire
un tête-à-queue à 180 degrés et qui a
mené pendant trois quatre ans une
politique exactement à l'opposé de ce
qu'il prône maintenant c'est pas sérieux
c'est là où la crédibilité du président
de la république est totalement ruiné
vous savez je vous dire une chose il
s'agit en fait de changer non seulement
en france mais deux j'ai la machine
européenne et de remettre les politiques
au pouvoir
parce que ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
a vécu pendant 20 ans en moi je vous le
dis parce que je me suis opposé au sein
même de mon parti à certaines mesures et
certaines politiques et je leur ai dit
en europe ils ont construit une usine à
gaz qui est en train de s'écrouler donc
il faut reprendre en main tout cela il
faut que la dg à ses intérêts cet idéal
à la fameuse
direccte direction de la concurrence
intègre la politique industrielle
adapte ses règles et à bandol de toute
concurrence sept complices aider les
entreprises pour s'installer dans des
villes comme saint claude afin
effectivement de ramener je dirais de
créer des emplois dans des villes à
taille humaine des villes à taille
humaine ça c'est important une chose est
sûre c'est que sans ça je serai en 2021
le pire déficit commercial de son
histoire 96 4 7 milliards d'euros vous
propose d'écouter les explications de
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a plus de 80
milliards d'euros de déficit il y à la
fracture énergétique et
l'affaiblissement industriels des trente
dernières années
c'est le sujet que nous avons commencé à
redresser avec le président de la
république en créant un environnement
fiscal plus favorable en baissant les
impôts de production en formant et en
qualifiant les salariés à de nouveaux
métiers industriels
loïc présente donc le plan de métro
emmanuel macron la baisse des impôts de
production votre réponse il ya du bon
quand même selon vous c'est ce que je
disais tout au début en fait c'est une
concurrence à la fiscalité la plus basse
est donc finalement on est dans une
espèce de de course à l'échalote sur
celui qui baissera le plus ses impôts
pour essayer d'attirer
des investisseurs ou de re créer de
l'emploi mais je voulais dit vous
trouverez toujours moins cher ailleurs
aussi on veut faire concurrence avec la
roumanie c'est une course enfin je veux
dire on n'y arrivera pas et je suis
absolument d'accord avec monsieur myard
et je le dis de bonne grâce le marché a
failli là dessus et donc quand je vous
dis que moi il faut mettre des mesures
de protectionnisme fort sur ces
questions sociales c'est évident que
c'est la seule la seule façon de faire
et le plan et jeu une fois plus je
souscris aux propos de jacques meyer
c'est que c'est le président macron a
fait exactement le contraire pendant
cinq ans et aujourd'hui il nous il nous
vend à un plan de relance qui sera
inopérant puisqu'il ne veut pas revenir
sur cette question de la concurrence
libre et non faussée ou des marchés sont
entièrement ouvert joli du tout à
l'heure il peut pas en même temps faire
des ponts d'or amazon et à toutes ces
grandes multinationales et puis espérer
sauver nos pme avec des ddd plan de
relance des pseudo plan de relance non
ça ne fonctionne pas et ça ne
fonctionnera jamais donc voilà ça c'est
une évidence et je pense que les faits
l'ont prouvé par le passé et les mêmes
les mêmes remèdes prou les mêmes pseudo
remède pour provoquant les mêmes effets
c'est à dire qu' il n'y aura rien en
termes de réindustrialisation de
création d'emplois vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure d'un solde positif sur les
relocalisations
mais c'est quel type d'entreprise et
pour combien d'emplois c'est ça qu'il
faut regarder c'est le solde des emplois
mais ce solde des emplois il n'est pas
positif et effectivement les emplois
créés ne compense pas ceux supprimés
d'ailleurs on peut le voir dans sur un
graphique ça veut dire jacques myard et
ce sera le le mot de la fin voilà on le
voit on pourrait supprimer ne compense
pas les emplois créés ne compense pas
ceux supprimés jacques myard il ya une
forme d'impuissance et ça sera loin de
la fin notamment d'ordre c'est le
président de la république on l'a vu il
y avait peut-être une forme de sincérité
quand il s'est rendu à bridgestone dans
le nord pas de calais dire voilà on ne
vous fermera pas et c'est impossible
manifestement et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est un problème d'investissement
c'est un problème de d'investir dans des
entreprises qui vont s'installer dans
des endroits où les gens sont beaucoup
plus heureux où il y à des logements
sovac ans il faut le savoir donc il est
toujours plus possible et je dirais aisé
d des entreprises à s'installer dans ces
villes où il y a une tradition
industrielle que de faire fuir les gens
en région parisienne où ils ont connu
des difficultés pour se loger donc il
est évident que de ce côté là que ce
soit monsieur le maire ou monsieur
macron il est temps de l'ordre des
avocats est à que permanent ça suffit
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
jacques myard et loïc prud'hommes
heureusement qu'on a appelée sans un
décryptage est pas un face à face vous
étiez parfaitement d'accord qui l'eût
cru merci à vous deux en tout cas